follow I was just warming myself by the
fire welcome to badass bitches of
history i'm jenny zigrino my guest today
is and hutches kid i didn't know you
liked football watch football and you
sure you should be doing that while
you're pregnant
i stood up against the church the
government and i was on trial whilst
making this friggin bun I think I can
handle my gross so we're doing this
mama's got a piss like a racehorse we're
here in seventeenth-century Boston and
Ann Hutchinson is a mother she's a
midwife Nana was wicked smaht I'm
chilling in the new colony of Boston way
before New York was around cuz Yankees
suck and John went throat was the
governor also a massive asshole and
while she's chillin she starts preaching
her own version of the Bible from her
home oh my waters just broke
between people believe in a covenant of
grace are you okay yeah had 15 of these
things that was fast
so anyway my sermons were the they
were talk of the town but the dudes of
Boston had huge egos and tiny dicks so I
got jealous we the people of Boston the
men of Boston formally declare and
Hutchinson to be guilty of heresy and
also kind of be in a bitch go
yourself Smith smile wouldn't kill you
honey I was killing it during my trial I
stood up for what I believed in
religious friggin freedom I told those
dickheads off and I almost won too
almost until she said God spoke to her
gotcha God doesn't talk to women she is
guilty then they banished her to road
Island okay sure you got
banished but we did name a highway after
you and the Bronx oh yeah yeah real
frigging honor having my road in the
same bar oh it's Yankee Stadium that was
a real friggin punishment but Anne you
inspire people who fight for truth and
justice yeah you see my kid I I was just
uh never mind it's cool I'll make a new
one
rise not too bad
look lobster rolls and there's one big
city look at that there's a guy in a
boat who doesn't like a guy in a boat
[Music]